There was a, you know,
what's so ridiculous is all these commercials now that are socially conscious.
It's like, it's like, dude,
just cause we're going through COVID you don't have to make a
commercial about how socially distancing is important.
Okay. Is Zuzu like, dude,
make a car just because,
just because you're practicing social distancing doesn't mean you can't remain
connected, make a car. There was a row.
I don't remember if it was like a Acura or some infinity. I think it was do it.
What? What's a infinity anyway. Like there's too many of them.
I don't know one person with one and I would never know somebody with an
infinity ever in my life. If my friend had an infinity, I go like this. Oh,
I thought I knew you. But dude
also infinity picks like the weird numbers and letters and. It's like a Q 35.
It's like, dude, what, what am I, James Bond? It's a,
[inaudible] a [inaudible] you do what Audi does.
It's like Q Audi has a queue. As a matter of fact,
whatever. Don't listen to me. But my point is the, I think it was infinity.
And it was like in times,
like the dude don't every commercial in times.
Like these with the time like this, with that,
where cubes staying connected is more important than ever. Oh yeah. Okay.
Velveeta. It's a put it in my mouth.
It's so ridiculous.
It's important with times any time a product is telling me how important the
time is. I'm out. I'm out, man.
Make the product commercial suck. Hire me. I'll be like, Hey,
you want these pants? Get these pants. These pants are the best pants.
I'll Trump it up.
Yeah. Do it. Socially-conscious commercials are the worst. You you're just,
you're trying to, you're a commercial.
You're trying to get us to buy your product.
Why are you being socially conscious? What was the ad?
Where the really one where people were like,
I think it was a shaving one where they were like a shaver one where they were
like, it was some like you don't need to be. Um, it was so ridiculous.
It was like, you don't need to be a man to shave your beard. I was like,
all right, dude. It was like, I can't remember what it was,
but it was so pandering. The second I could smell the agenda I'm out.
I don't like to smell the agenda.
I can't smell the agenda. Dude.
During times like these it's more important then ever.
How many commercials have started that, that way during times,
like these it's more important than ever to visit living
spaces. Do you need end tables?
Well, remember we're here for you during times.
Like these comfortability is more important than ever.
We know a lot's going on in the world.
So here at radio shack, come get a VCR.
Hey, radio shack. How do we still exist?
My buddy Dean Del Ray has the funniest bit about radio shack.
I don't remember it, buddy. You'd be like, why is it,
how is there still a radio shack? Um,
anyway, Hey, come on,
come on guys by this. But during times,
like these were more here for you than any place. Home Depot.
They'll do it with home Depot. Like they give a, dude,
you need wood. During times like these,
we understand the structure of society, maybe collapsing,
but we're not home Depot
during times like days we know it's going to be awful and you might get
COVID hookers were here for you
when you thought life sucked. We're here to suck it back. Oh,
curse. Slobbing on your knob.
Aye. Hookers one, the oldest profession in the world,
way older than COVID hookers. Wash your hands also hookers.
Just, just because it's harder to stay connected in the real world.
Doesn't mean it's hard.
It should be hard to connect your into a hookers or a or a mouth
hookers.
We want you to feel sensation. Oh. That was so loud.
Um, in my, in my headphones anyway,